there is a new iPhone coming if you go
to yahoo.com every day there's 18
stories before they get to anything else
about the new iPhone 6 and a designer
named Sam Beckett has come up with a
mock-up of what he thinks the iPhone 6
is gonna look like and he's using a lot
of contextual clues from things that are
leaking out of China and things like
that and we've got a little video for
you oh my god have you ever seen
anything sexier in your life and that
music I mean the guy should work for
Apple and make commercials because that
was pretty good actually some of the
things that they're saying that the
iPhone 6 is going to have a larger 4.7
inch display which is up from 4 inches
0.7 inches that's a pretty good
resolution of 1920 by 1080 which is 68
percent more pixels and it's gonna be
nine percent thinner of course this is
not confirmed this is just what they're
saying all right so we talked a lot
about the Apple stuff here are you guys
both iPhone or an iPhone er I do but I'm
probably going to jump ship next time
all right let's we'll get to that in a
moment why you're gonna do it am some
guy you're a Samsung guys you're
fighting the power in a way my own in my
own sort of way I write my carrier
originally didn't carry the iPhone so
like by default I was fighting the power
and now I just kind of you know fallen
in line like that what carrier were you
I was a with t-mobile at t-mobile now
you can do it but you'd have done all
right I would have to you know and it
was this big thing and I like here's the
thing the number one thing about the
iPhone what I really can't handle is
that it doesn't matter if the screen is
bigger doesn't matter if there's more
pixels and it's thinner like I need
something that's not gonna shatter when
I like knock it off my nightstand in the
middle of like a night terror
you know I need something that can like
fall out of my pocket at crazy girls on
the Sunset Strip and not be broken into
a million pieces and so for that reason
alone I really like the plastic displays
of the Samsung I did not know you suffer
from night terror good luck with that
it's a real crazy girl so because the
crazy girls well supposedly the glass on
this new
is gonna be some super-strong thing that
you literally were able to like throw it
on the ground and we're not affected why
are you considering jumping ship I
really a camera I don't think it's the
best quality camera I get that weird
white fuzz when I take darker pictures I
just want a better camera so this is all
about camera for me do you guys think
that with this technology that sometimes
you're actually in too deep to ever get
out because that's sort of how that's
sort of how I feel with the iPhone 6 I
feel like it's the Mafia like it's easy
to get in but it's hard to get out like
everything I have I have a MacBook I
have an iPad I have an iPhone it's like
I get how would I even do it it would be
scary to me to be like no no I'm moving
but it's not even fanboy it's literally
like it's not about the fanboy part it's
literally the part where it's well how
am I going to now sync this thing with
my old pictures and all that kind of
stuff give me take some work invitation
I have to bring in a professional maybe
even a genius do you think a lot of
people feel that because there is this
growing don't you feel this growing
resentment of Apple they've become the
monolith that they used to rail against
in that famous 1984 commercial and
that's what they've become right without
a doubt I mean I think that after you
saw the Steve Jobs movie kind of could
never really buy another Apple product
in good faith and I and I also think
that because a movie stock was a bad
story it's a great story I love Steve
Jobs yeah but you know I I started
waning myself off of alpha products
about two years ago because I was like
you know what I was spending so much
money on these things and they you know
they're really just not very robust so I
switched over to a PC for editing you
know for our show we use all pcs and
it's a lot cheaper they're a lot easier
to sort of like finagle and mess with
and I think for for bang for buck you
know it's like you're you're kind of
like that that hipster guy who's hanging
on you know to the fixed gear bicycle if
you're if you're still like super Apple
fanboy you know these days you said PC
and finagle in the same sentence that
might be the nerdiest thing that's ever
been said that's not even like like like
comic book nerd which is like a
different level of social anxiety yeah
how much of this does go to the Steve
Jobs thing that because he's not there
it seems like they're not innovating
anymore that's what everyone's saying
that even these little specks okay some
more pixels a slightly nicer camera
thinner but they're not reinventing
themselves and they haven't since he's
been since he's been gone has done a
pretty good job but you know it's a
little thinner it's really the the
innovator that Steve Jobs was I yes
these specs are just improving slightly
each time the 5s to many people was a
disappointment yeah we wanted something
more maybe something bigger maybe
different vastly different specs and
it's just a slight upgrade each time and
the 5c was a huge flop actually and
they're partly saying that's because it
was cheaper and Apple people want to
spend more money which is going to be a
luxury item yeah is that would you not
buy something because it was cheaper
with that team no I mean I bought the
Samsung phone because it was so much
cheaper and yeah for me it's like it's a
phone you know it's like I need I need
Google Docs and that's how you can get
away from the cloud issue and syncing
and everything like that you just have
something that's surprising you just
have to trust Google because you module
right because Google not a problem
Apple problem actually I was driving on
Santa Monica yesterday and I was being
followed by a Google car I'm not kidding
I mean I think it was really following
me but I mean it was behind me that
that's scary that they're just Google's
just driving around with cameras filming
the whole damn thing
right here we are and also building
robots but bought an evil robot factory
Boston Dynamics so you know those things
could ever get together and cause any
trouble for anybody you think they'll be
a problem they're gonna have robots on
the streets and drones and yeah not only
Boston Dynamics but at least six major
robotics firms and it makes people
wonder what are they going to do next
with what is their next plan because
they've started to get into hardware
didn't go so well we're ho BOTS are the
epitome of hardware especially what you
know Boston Dynamics makes very lifelike
strong fast robots right so when someone
comes knocking on your door asking for
John Connor you'll know there's a
problem
you give them John Connor alright final
thought I listen every time we've done
an Apple thing I've asked this question
does do they end up losing their mojo in
the next year or two because of this
sort of building thing of a not bringing
us products that are revolutionary again
because it's been a couple years of
they're just
and then be just this general feeling of
like you're so cool you're not cool
anymore a general feeling I feel as Liz
has really proliferated like we see
these Samsung commercials with a bunch
of dumb hipster standing in line like
sheep and not really thinking on their
own and then that kind of general
malaise just kind of takes over even if
the products themselves they're not bad
products they're good products but the
mentality is getting stronger and
stronger yeah as a style icon is a
status symbol I think Apple you know
obviously just like any other trend
first it was Tommy Hilfiger and then it
was you know not and then it was back to
Tommy Hilfiger and I think that things
just you know I've been Flo what Apple
has done though over their history you
know they had some rough times people
counted out apples so many times I think
they're in a much better position you
know as far as market Capon and
viability to continue to make really
good products and if they are gonna
continue to make good products and
they'll be fine
yeah and by the way for those of you
that think Apple might actually be in
trouble you know during the Oscars Ellen
did the the selfie heard around the
world 3 million-plus retweets that was
on a Samsung phone which obviously was
paid for for her do but backstage she
was tweeting on her iPhone so there you
go